discovering inventive new games well I
don't have any buffalo wings but I do
have something just as tasty over the
past couple of years
EA is partnered with the amazing Studios
like haze light and joy to give us such
creative titles as a way out in faith
here to explain how they do it are a few
of the talented developers working on
the next wave of EA originals
sometimes you just have this great idea
of the game but it can be really hard to
do it on your own cool we wanted space
for our Studios creativity can flow free
so that we can try unconventional
approaches to solving new ideas there
are times where you've got to like break
past your own sort of mental blocks even
if that meant building a whole new kind
of game engine we get to do the game we
want to do nothing and I mean nothing
comes into the game if it doesn't follow
the vision we can really push our ideas
further and bigger than we first
imagined let's find that magic
[Music]
and now for a deeper dive into what
these developers are working on we turn
our spotlight on three Studios up first
is haze light in their mild-mannered
quiet leader Joseph Farris let's do it
please welcome
Joseph fair as there are like passionate
people there crazy people there's me
[Music]
okay can you swear here kiss Tuskers you
know not polish is there a yeah I know
I'm coffee I can't help it man I was
born in Beirut 1977
I lived there 10 years of a civil war
and there was a lot of bad stuff
happening there we tried to move five
times to Sweden the fifth time they let
us in and that's lucky for Sweden
because I've given feeling a lot to know
my third movies those are is basically
about my life when I came to Sweden when
I was young I've done five fishing
movies and I've done three games and
it's very hard to make a game it's
almost like the audience have controlled
of the pacing on the story while the
movies is being paced for you in video
games there's so much to be explored
from a storytelling perspective because
of the interactivity there are some
students out there that are making into
have good stories but they pretty much
have one mechanic like Yuri use all the
time the designers and the story writers
are kind of like doing two different
games that's why I founded his life to
keep pushing the boundaries of what is
possible in games
that's what game number three from his
life is all about
action the new game it takes to is a
co-op action-adventure platformer that
would blow your mind away the story
starts out with a small family Cody may
that's the parents and then bros the
little daughters so Cody may about
separate Rose doesn't want to be
divorced two secrets to dogs at a wood
and clay and these dogs magically come
alive and actually controls both Cody
and May and you could say you're almost
controlling their emotions you're always
playing in their emotions there's even
levels where we're actually making them
mechanic for their emotions so again
marrying the story and the mechanics and
I think for the players that's gonna
feel very new different and unique they
haven't played anything like this before
it takes two is a crazy roller coaster
ride that doesn't really have an enemy
it has an ending but that endings that
the roller coaster crashes and you fly
into the sky and get up into space and
when you're his preys you like what am i
doing up here and then maybe you get
back to to earth again it's not the best
way to describe that it takes to
actually
Wow that would that was the best way to
describe it all right Joseph we love you
so much thank you keep it up over there
the Oscars of course ladies and
gentlemen let's keep this originals
train rolling and let's stay in Sweden
for some a fan of both their delicious
red gummy fish and their video games so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Klaus and Olaf from joint games thanks
Greg
welcome to Gothenburg and will my home
unfortunately I didn't bring you any
Swedish fish but we do have some
exciting news for you about our latest
game at sewing we've always been driven
by love of rich visual storytelling and
creating strange worlds that people can
escape to the weirder the better and I
think my friend Olaf would agree yeah
absolutely and for our next game though
we wanted to try something a little
darker something out of a gothic fairy
tale but started with a mood and some
painting screw into this eerie strange
world that feels like something out of a
beautiful twisted dream and that's the
world of random lost and random is the
story of even a little girl with a big
heart and an even bigger temper after a
horrible event the changes of life she
embarks on a dangerous journey through
the world random but fortunately she's
not alone just like I have below even
also has a crazy little weird friend
thing with her along her journey even
discovers dicey a playful loyal almost
puppy like dice companion that gives her
the power to really change things in the
kingdom of random
despite the name an even swirled
randomness is feared and the dark force
controls every aspect of life from where
you live to how your act or what your
favorite color is it's a coming-of-age
story set against the backdrop of a
mysterious world but it holds a modern
message that's really relevant to our
world right now I think we can all
relate to the desire to try and control
the chaos around us with Dicey's help
though human learns the power doing just
the opposite
embrace the randomness accept
uncertainties in life and you'll be
surprised how far it takes you imagine
if you could change the course of life
with a roll of a dice what would you do
play it safe or trust in yourself and
take a chance we can't wait for you to
play and find out we're still a long
ways from launch but we hope you will
join even and dicey on the journey next
year until then please enjoy this first
look at lost and random will come to
random
the world of random bends with the roar
of one guy's a die set is rule this
kingdom for generations transforming the
fates of people just like you but what
if I told you there is another dice with
the power to change everything now my
friend it's your turn to roll to play
the odds and break the curse of random
[Music]
we can't have the sweet without the sour
I know dicey they should be scared of us
right
[Music]
really cool that's a little get lost in
random in man embracing randomness I
feel like I live that every day my life
you know is gonna do that you didn't
know that die seize my spirit animal the
game's out next year but for something
that's blasting off a whole lot sooner
take it away Kevin Franklin
final strike games our team of
experienced industry veterans have
worked on incredible multiplayer
franchises we are passionately focused
on making great multiplayer games that's
why I am incredibly excited to announce
that we have partnered with the talented
team at EA to release our first ever
title rocket arena as you'll see we stay
loyal to the name of the game
it's a rockets only shooter that allows
players to get into the action quickly
and stay in the fight we want a rocket
Iranian to be an awesome competitive
experience to play with friends I think
you're gonna love what we've got in
store for you here is the all-new
trailer of rocket arena enjoy rockets
away
[Music]
have you ever wondered why life is so
good on crater sure we've got the
beautiful beaches quality public
transportation and exotic destinations
the people are courteous and friendly
always happy to help their fellowship
but the real reason life is so good
[Music]
let's fit the trail
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
turn your back on the water
[Music]
I'm here to rocket
whoa
so as you just saw rockets are obviously
awesome to blast all over the place but
in order to come out on top there's a
lot to master you'll have a range of
rocket-powered abilities to blast
opponents out of the arena and an
arsenal of evasive moves rocket jump
rocket climb and dodge to avoid getting
knocked out yourself
don't worry though you're never out of
the action for long even when you're out
you'll fly right back into the fray
you'll also be able to really customize
your own unique look and play style each
of the 10 year is available at launch
have their own rocket-powered abilities
and as you play you'll discover items
that allow you to further refine each of
your heroes play styles Plus every
character has a hundred levels of
progression that unlock new cosmetics
and rewards all that and much more when
rocket arena arrives on July 14th and
there's plenty more content to come in
our first season which begins just two
weeks after launch on July 28th and
brings with it a blast pass and a ton of
free content including new maps in game
events and a new playable character
rocket arena is a game meant to be
played with friends regardless of
platform that's why we're thrilled to
announce cross play support right from
the start
so grab your friends regardless of their
platform and get ready to blast off with
rocket arena on July 14th on PlayStation
Xbox origin and steam and we'll be
sharing more gameplay right after the
show with the help of some great content
creators so check us out on youtube at
the link below see you in the arena wow
that looks great and hopefully you